il est 18 heures si vous nous rejoignez
en direct lors du journal de la
rédaction sur tv fil 78
bienvenue donc et en ce 28 janvier 2015
les principaux titres à un collectif
s'organise à magny les hameaux contre la
réalisation de 33 logements au
rond-point de chris lye les riverains
craignent entre autres un engorgement
des routes
le lobbying des notaires se poursuit ils
ne veulent pas de la réforme macron qui
doit toucher leur profession ils le font
savoir depuis plusieurs mois alors que
le projet de loi passe actuellement
devant les députés nous revenons sur les
raisons de cette opposition
la pédagogie montessori une méthode
d'éducation dit ouverte où l'on dispense
une aide à la vie une école à maurepas
propose ses enseignements elle organise
des portes ouvertes ce week end la
directrice et une éducatrice seront tout
à l'heure en plateau pour nous en parler
pour débuter la une du journal municipal
de magny les hameaux que vous avez peut
être découvert dans votre boîte aux
lettres le maire a décidé de rendre
hommage à hommage à charlie hebdo en
rebaptisant le temps d'un numéro à
manille magma nymag devenu charlie mc
bertrand guillon qui souligne dans son
éditorial son attachement à la laïcité
garantie de la liberté de la presse et à
magny les hameaux justement un projet de
réalisation de 33 logements au
rond-point de chris lye pose problème
les habitants à s'inquiète de la
situation de la circulation à venir ils
protestent également sur la hauteur des
logements un collectif vient de se créer
400 signatures ont déjà été collectés
catherine plateau et le diwan sylviane
martineau comptent et recomptent les
signatures recueillies par la pétition
lancée il ya quelques mois
400 personnes ont signé pour dire non la
construction de deux immeubles de 33
logements sur cette parcelle une
parcelle située devant le rond-point de
chris lee un axe très passant et dix
mille véhicules par jour la 33 logements
c'est au moins 70 véhicules
alors sachant que le matin ça bouchonne
sur cette route de versailles qui est un
problème de visibilité d'accès la sortie
qui va se trouver à peu près au niveau
du premier lampadaire vous rendez compte
la dangerosité
deux bâtiments devraient être construits
ici d'une hauteur de 14 m pour christian
cher vos dons la maison donne
directement sur le terrain c'est la
déconvenue avec moi une vue directe
magnifique sur sur les immeubles qui
seront après peut-être jolie ou pas mais
aussi une vue directe sur la sortie parc
14 mètres de hauteur de bâtiments
d'une architecture tout à fait simple
très ordinaire on comprend qu'il faut
construire mais essayons de respecter
environnement le devenir aussi de bain
de notre ville du plateau
c'est pour ça qu'on a eu le soutien de
toutes les associations de la région du
coin pour la mairie l'équation est
différente construire c'est maintenir un
niveau de population et répondre aux
demandes de logement mille sont en cours
d'instruction dans la commune
magny les hameaux n'a pas eu d'évolution
de population depuis 1995 quasiment
stable à 400 habitants près sur les 9000
donc et la dernière année même en 2000
en 2014 une diminution population notre
objectif c'est une stabilité de notre
population je peux comprendre les
inquiétudes qu'il peut y avoir
notre objectif est que sur les accès à
ces logements tout soit fait pour éviter
de d'apporter des nuisances aux
riverains en termes de parking en
souterrain et puis en termes de de
paysagement avec un recul plus important
qu'à la base de l'ensemble du bâtiment
une nouvelle réunion est prévue ce mardi
soir avec les riverains mais le permis
de construire a déjà été adopté des
modifications apportées au projet
initial
le chantier pourrait démarrer dans le
courant de l'année les cheminots de
versailles se sont réunis mercredi pour
un meeting la réunion était organisée en
garde versailles-chantiers objectif
débattre de la réforme ferroviaire et de
ses conséquences
le syndicat cgt des cheminots a reçu à
cette occasion le soutint soutien de
peter pic mais le président du syndicat
britannique des cheminots un mouvement
qui compte 80 mille adhérents outre
manche le leader anglais a pris la
parole devant l'assemblée pendant près
d'une heure je pense que ma présence ici
un sens se convaincre une seule personne
serait déjà une satisfaction cette
dernière pour en parler à une autre cela
permettra d'élever le niveau de
conscience dans ce cas là ma venue
permettra d'apporter ma pierre à
l'édifice du combat je veux montrer que
les compagnies sont unis au delà des
frontières on doit être aussi une icône
aux patrons à l'international
on essaie de faire comprendre que quand
un travailleur français est attaqué
c'est aussi un travailleur anglais
quittent attaquer il faut qu'on se batte
tous ensemble aujourd'hui le chemin de
fer en angleterre n'est pas un moyen de
transport sûr alors que c'est le pays du
rail c'est le premier pays au monde dans
lequel on a on a construit reiss est
extraordinaire c'est une régression
colossal en vérité donc oui ça nous
intéresse parce qu'on veut pas que ça
arrive en france on pense que on en
prend le chemin
et que sa légitime le fait que pour nous
il faut qu'on se batte balade dans les
yvelines
ça que les choses n'ont pas traîné
depuis l'adoption de la loi sur la
réforme ferroviaire
on a fermé les bureaux grandes lignes
les guichets grandes lignes devant de
grandes lignes à plaisir grignon on en
supprime un sur deux à rambouillet on va
fermer celui de versailles rive gauche
l'a donc oui il ya déjà des conséquences
graves pour les usagers qui perdent leur
guichet de proximité sncf les agents
périscolaire de plaisir ont manifesté
aujourd'hui suite à l'appel d'une
intersyndicale cgt cfdt sud et fo ils
étaient une quarantaine devant la mairie
pour réclamer plus de postes et des
primes supplémentaires
on écoute tout d'abord andrée habitants
le secrétaire cfdt de plaisir en premier
on pourra dire le régime indemnitaire
qui soit qu'ils soient vraiment réévalué
est rehaussée 1 parce que toutes ces
pousses le cas
et pour tous donc pour ça il faudra une
enveloppe une augmentation de l'
enveloppe du régime indemnitaire
afin de récompenser tous ces agents qui
se sont vraiment défoncé cette année
après dans le détail a énormément de
choses mais ça serait trop loin vous
expliquer mais avec déjà des moyens
débloqués on va faire beaucoup de choses
on a octroyé pour tous les jours et pour
les animateurs également tring de
tutorat pour les animateurs encadrant le
contrat aidé et des indemnités
collective aux métriques pour les
remplaçants atteignent indicateurs quand
ils déplacent sur la collectivité donc
on a fait une avancée financières
d'accompagnement énorme qui va bien au
delà des 45000 euros et aussi quand même
vous savez aujourd'hui les collectivités
ont des temps de difficultés grande donc
c'est ce que j'essaye d'expliquer
désespérément représentants et
personnelle mais nouveau depuis défendre
ce qu'on m'a dit que j'avais absolument
pas d'action syndicale ça voulait dire
ça y est la grève et que maintenant il
est cher des actions famille kahn savait
toujours du mal mais j'avais pas été du
tout près des durées des petites maïs
dans laquelle il faut quand même très
fier que on appuie était qu'il y avait
des personnes à l'intérieur qui s'était
absolument pas partie de la vie de
plaisirs il faisait partie de sud qui
est un dos par représenter sur la ville
et d'autres pas le mouvement pourrait un
émoi à prendre de l'ampleur une nouvelle
manifestation devrait être organisée
mardi prochain devant la mairie avec
cette fois ci d 1,6 docteur probablement
la loi macron continue aussi de
mobiliser les professions réglementées
cette fois-ci parmi elles celle ci les
notaires il était dans la rue en début
de semaine il évoque un drame social
probable dans leurs rangs mélanie poquet
elodie -955 c'est le nombre d'emplois
menacés dans les yvelines par la loi
macron c'est du moins ce qu'estiment les
notaires la réforme sur les professions
réglementées vise notamment les tarifs
pour introduire plus de concurrence
par exemple pour une
immobilière quand on parle des frais de
notaire qui représente approximativement
7 % des frais et bien il ya un peu plus
de 5% qui reviennent à l'état
le notaire ayant quant à lui partagé
avec l'autre notaire un émolument en
honoraires qui est de l'ordre d'un petit
peu moins 1 % des honoraires
or aujourd'hui le projet doit macron et
qui est d'ailleurs aidé en cela par le
le rapport qui a été établie par
l'autorité de la concurrence de remettre
complètement en cause cette rémunération
de sorte que nous n'aurons plus les
moyens demain d'exercer notre métier
comme il se doit
un quart des études notariales serait
rapidement en cessation de paiement pour
appuyer leur propos les professionnels
prennent exemple d'une réforme identique
appliqué aux pays bas depuis 1999 37 %
des emplois auraient disparu
les tarifs eux auraient augmenté de plus
de 10% dans les transactions
immobilières de 97 % pour les testaments
et 60% pour les contrats de mariage la
loi macron veut aussi instituer la
liberté d'installation
et sur ce plan certains experts y sont
favorables
les chargés de pompiers j'ai compris je
pense que cette tradition de
transmission la loi est examiné à
l'assemblée nationale depuis le lundi 26
janvier
les notaires eux ne baissent pas les
bras et envisage d'autres manifestations
il est question d'éducation à présent
dans ce journal nous allons évoquer avec
nos invités la pédagogie montessori
bonsoir daniel vivier du vivier bien sûr
cette présidente fondatrice en 1985 et
directrice du centre de rencontres
enfantine montessori à maurepas et
bonsoir laurence debroux éducatrice
montessori à maurepas donc également
établissements qui vont organiser des
portes ouvertes ce sera samedi 31
janvier
partir de 10h et puis l'après midi à
partir de 14 heures la pédagogie
montessori c'est une méthode d'éducation
dit ouverte l'éducation est considérée
comme une aide à la vie vous allez nous
dire concrètement ce que là cela
signifie pour les enfants qui viennent
dans votre établissement ce sera juste
après notre question du jour
micro-trottoir connaissez vous cette
pédagogie et qu'en pensez vous pas du
tout jamais je pense une école d'art non
je suis pas sûr non je ne connais pas je
pense que c'est vraiment plus voilà m
l'enfant dans des situations enfin
peut-être donner plus de liberté à
l'enfant être plus à l'écouté de
l'enfant je pense que c'est intéressant
que ça mérite
d'être creusée de voir si ça pouvait pas
être étendu dans le système dans le
système enfin dans l'éducation nationale
je fais que naïna maurepas d'ailleurs
juste pas que la petite fille ira parce
que c'est vraiment une méthode
fantastique d'aller au rythme de
l'enfant est pas comme dans l'éducation
nationale où là c'est très simple ans on
ne connaît pas du tout soit on est déjà
adeptes et convaincu par la méthode
montessori plus de liberté à l'enfant
c'est ce qu'on a pu entendre à ce que
c'est ça pour raisonner oui c'est à dire
que l'on donne à l'enfant des des
exercices à faire il les fait quand il
veut dans la journée et autant de fois
qu'il le veut surtout chez les tout
petits chez les plus grands c'est plus
des exercices qu'on a l'habitude de voir
mais ils s'organisent comme ils veulent
dans la journée dans leur travail dans
leur programme la base de la méthode
développée par la pédagogue italienne
maria montessori c'est que chaque enfant
est unique
en fait on voit au rythme de chacun des
enfants au rythme d'apprentissage oui
mais au rythme d'apprentissage si malgré
tout parce que vous nous disiez tout à
l'heure
l'enfant fait l'exercice quand il a
envie ça peut paraître surprenant pour
les parents si l'enfant n'a jamais envie
quand ils sont tout petits sont toujours
en vie et ils sont très contents de
venir à l'école même quand même en
primaire dans quelques fois ils ont
envie de jouer plus que de travailler
parce que d exercice fastidieux en
primaire la grammaire l'orthographe en
français en particulier mais par exemple
l'histoire la géographie les sciences
ils sont complètement passionné pour les
exercices les plus compliqués stimule un
petit peu d'accord il ya des façons de
les amener à faire l'exercice en tout
cas ils ont le sentiment que c'est eux
qui ont envie de le faire et pas qu'on
leur impose
laurence debroux vous êtes en charge
vous du du groupe 20 mois 3 ans sont les
plus petits mais la méthode montessori
pour les plus petits ça correspond à
quoi alors c'est correspond déjà on
accueille quinze enfants
avec ma collègue anglophone donc il ya
un bain de langage en français et en
anglais dans ce groupe là qui est
valable dans tous les autres groupes
aussi nous donnons la possibilité aux
enfants en fin de compte de collaborer à
toutes les actions de leur vie
quotidienne qui sont liées aux soins de
la personne mais aussi aux soins de
l'environnement c'est à dire que autant
de fois qu'on le désire que l'enfant le
désire il va pouvoir boutonnée
déboutonnée sa petite chemise se servir
à boire
coupez la banane pour la manger ensuite
ou pour l'offrir aux enfants dans la
classe se sont que des actions de la vie
quotidienne chez les tout-petits et des
activités liées ou sont là de
l'environnement ça peut être nettoyé la
table avec les pauvres parce que on a
renversé un petit peu d'eau sur la table
la vie la vaisselle arroser les plantes
nourrir les poissons mais aussi par eux
mêmes l'autonomie qui a favorisé tout à
fait tout à fait à ce que l'on pense pas
à pas par rapport à toutes ces activités
que l'onf on va répéter il va il va
développer deux de la première attention
qu'il va porter à tout l'environnement
il va développer sa concentration pour
arriver à la tâche qui qui qui l'a
choisie par exemple se servir de l'eau
dans un ferr pour un petit enfant de
deux ans et c'est pas c'est pas facile
donc ils s'exercent il renverse est pas
grave va les chercher l'eponge et puis
ensuite donc du coup va naître la
confiance et de cette confiance l'enfant
va être de plus en plus autonome et il
va construire estime de soi qui est un
élément essentiel pour les
apprentissages après plus tard le groupe
c 20 mois trois ans où la cohabitation
entre des enfants qui ont trois ans et
ceux qui ont 20 - justement dans la
pédagogie montessori on veut absolument
le mélange tâche parce que les plus
grands apporte plus jeunes et les plus
jeunes apporte plus gros si on est dans
un climat de bienveillance et
et chacun chacun va apporter aux autres
ce sont des groupes par périodes dites
sensibles
c'est ça c'est comme ça que ça a
forcément les périodes sensibles mais
les groupes après le groupe dès 2 3 ans
il ya le groupe 3 6 ans je mélange est
aussi et ensuite le primaire 6 9 ans et
9 12 ans ça correspond à quoi cette
période justement les périodes sensibles
que que j'évoquais tout à l'heure alors
ce sont des périodes où l'enfant est
particulièrement récepteur à quelque
chose et il fait les choses sans effort
ça peut être effectivement pour que ça
parle aux parents l'apprentissage en
particulier la lecture de l'écriture et
des mathématiques
pour ce qui préoccupe les parents
quelles sont les motivations des parents
justement qui viennent vous vous
inscrire leurs enfants dans notre
établissement par exemple à maurepas
mais c'est qu'on respecte justement ces
rythmes d'apprentissage et qu'on leur
permette comme les qu'on ne leur impose
pas des activités si c'est pas le besoin
du moment pour l'enfant mais ça convient
à tous les enfants même s'il n'est pas
en aussi qu'ils inscrivent leurs enfants
et qui finalement se disent c'est très
bien la méthode mais ça ne convient pas
à mon enfant
plus ils sont jeunes plus ça leur
convient pas ce cas elle s'est basée
justement sur les étapes de
développement psychologique et de
développement moteur de l'enfant donc ça
convient à tous les enfants
c'est vrai comme l'inde est quand on a
des enfants qui arrivent en primaire et
qui n'ont pas été dans ce cursus
c'est un peu plus compliqué et alors par
la suite parce que ça va jusqu'à 11 ans
et ça pourra alors chez nous ça va
jusqu'à 11 ans mais il peut y avoir des
collèges montessori où là aussi c'est
encore l'autonomie est encore plus
favorisés c'est la microéconomie et se
lance presque dans la vie et ses enfants
qu'ils n'atteignent pas ensuite le
collège parce qu'on va y venir aussi
mais ça un coup un bien évidemment tout
ça qui finalement rejoignent un cursus
classique c'est difficile pour eux de
s'intégrer après avoir suivi
l'enseignement alors c'est pas plus
difficile c'est plus facile quand ils
sortent de 11 en particulier quand ils
ont fait vraiment tout le cursus c'est
c'est d'une facilité extrême la
réadaptation
ils sont mieux adaptés même que les a
passées c'est le retour que nous
disaient
anciens élèves et les parents parce
qu'ils sont autonomes et indépendants ri
savent prendre en charge leur travail et
donc je vois bien l'adaptation elle est
un peu par rapport aux gros mais d'une
certaine façon ils sont contents d'avoir
plus de copains aussi voulez vous les
préparez aussi comme ça à se dire que
bah c'est comme ça à l'école de la
méthode montessori mais c'est pas
forcément comme ça à l'extérieur donc à
conjuguer un petit peu a réalisé qu'il
ya des plus grands la double vie mais
quand son plus grand vous l'aurez
c'est quand ils sont plus grand quand y
sont quotidiens maintenant on ne dit pas
c'est vrai que par rapport à tout ce qui
se dit actuellement
enfin dans nos écoles c'est vrai
convient vraiment la liberté l'égalité
la fraternité
j'ai revu des anciens élèves samedi avec
leurs parents et en particulier sur la
fraternité sur l'entr'aide et sur la
cohésion du groupe
c'est ce qu'ils ont ressenti par rapport
à près au collège quand il ad ailleurs
il ya tout un débat aussi autour de
l'éducation nationale et pas uniquement
liée aux derniers événements tragiques
qui ont touché la france mais aussi par
rapport à la réforme des rythmes
scolaires
la refonte des programmes aussi
refondation des programmes sur les
rythmes scolaires par exemple qu'elle
regarde vous avez là dessus mais c'est
très compliqué parce que y'a le rythme
de l'enfant et que quel que soit ce
rythme scolaire ou ou le nôtre on ne
suivra pas ce qu'on suit surtout la
société et c'est vrai que le rythme
montessori ce serait des grandes matinée
jusqu'à 14 15 heures et met tous les
jours donc pour l'instant faudra encore
complètement revoir le système de
l'éducation nationale ont parlé des
motivations des parents il ya aussi un
frein peut-être c'est la question
financière aussi combien ça coûte une
scolarité à l'école montessori
ben ça va c'est variable sur toute la
france et l'ariane chez nous c'est de
l'ordre de 6000 à 6500 euros par an
parce qu'on n'a aucune aide donc ses
parents qui financent tous ces salaires
et il n'y a pas de contrat avec l'état
avec l'or il ya quelques écoles en
france qui ont des contrats mais nous
dans les yvelines comme il ya énormément
d'écoles privées sous contrat il n'y a
plus rien dans les enveloppes donc les
parents doivent financer les six mille
et quelques euros c'est très lourd c'est
très difficile ça ne s'adresse pas à
tout le monde
alors des litiges et ben oui un petit
peu alors quand même pour les moins de 6
ans nous on a fait le choix de se
déclarer en jardin d'enfants c'est à
dire dépendant de la dass ce qui fait
quand même et puis aussi parce que la
scolarisation n'est pas obligatoire
jusqu'à 6 ans donc les parents peuvent
déduire au même titre qui déduisent une
nourrice ou autres jusqu'à 6 ans au
moins jusqu'à 6 ans ils veulent
découvrir la méthode montessori si vous
voulez en savoir plus il ya des portes
ouvertes porte est ouverte donc ce
samedi le site internet de l'école à
maurepas et qui va s'afficher une
nouvelle fois pour avoir tous les
renseignements pratiques merci d'être
venu nous parler de cette pédagogie et
puis voilà ces portes ouvertes si vous
souhaitez inscrire vos enfants ont
poursuivi ce journal à présent culture
on va rester dans l'univers des enfants
la maîtrise d'un enfant de trappes sera
en concert ce dimanche à l'école de
musique de la ville dans le cadre de la
clôture de la semaine du son un moment
très important pour eux il était en
répétition ce mardi soir à la résidence
pour personnes âgées fourcassa les
images sont signés louise elle bride et
patrick jacq tu dixmude les commentaires
catherine je l'attend donc pour le coeur
des gens ont commencé à écouter dernier
conseil dernier placement gabrielle est
la chef de choeur à l'oeil
elle veut que tout soit parfait pour que
toutes les notes s'enchaînent
correctement comme des professionnels
les enfants de la maîtrise de trappes
font leur exercice anti qualité est allé
avec le congo
ce soir là il donne une représentation à
la résidence pour personnes âgées
fourcassa à train
se faire plaisir et faire plaisir je
crois au aux personnes âgées aussi qui
qui aiment la musique pour nous c'est
une expérience de plus en petit comité
de s'entraîner et de faire des choses
devant public
mais j'aime chanter et j'aime bien le
genre musical c'est surtout vient de
santé devant des personnes âgées parce
que je trouve ça vient je suis entré
très bien ils sont bien accompagner tout
c'est agréable
c'est la vie les enfants la maîtrise d
enfant de trappes a vu le jour en 2011 à
l'initiative du projet de la paix msq
l'association pour la promotion de la
musique à saint quentin en yvelines la
pms hvala ou peut-être d'autres n'osent
pas intervenir dans les quartiers
populaires là où la musique n'a pas tout
naturellement sa place il y a 4 ans 5
enfants composé la maîtrise aujourd'hui
ils sont une trentaine de 7 à 16 ans
parmi les airs interprétés ce soir là la
neuvième symphonie de dvorak accompagné
d'un message de paix tu enfin le froid
et la faim dans leurs yeux la frayeur au
tour de l'horreur est partout la misère
le mal triomphe en arrêter ça te dire au
monde dans ses textes existent depuis 25
ans maintenant depuis que j'enseigne aux
enfants et malheureusement c'est
toujours actuelle et c'est toujours
aussi émouvants c'est une période où il
faut
il faut témoigner aussi par les chants
et par les enfants que que voilà on est
on est tous contre de tous ces choses
qui nuit notre belle vie
les enfants de la maîtrise seront en
concert ce dimanche à l'auditorium de
l'école de musique de trappes ils seront
accompagnés de l'orchestré manifestants
une exposition à présent jusqu'au 1er
février la maison félix à montigny le
bretonneux présente des séries et
d'aquarelles cet artiste pour autant d'
approche de cette technique de peinture
105 tableau cette année de travail et
beaucoup d'eau c'est ce qu'il a fallu
aux cet aquarelliste amateurs pour
monter l'exposition méli mélo entre
portraits paysages mais aussi lave
vaisselle et ponceuse et des tableaux
qui n'ont pas fini de surprendre
on a mis en place cette exposition par
en se basant sur les couleurs en fait on
a fait des zones de couleur identique ou
presque pour que ce soit plus agréable à
l'oeil
il ya des endroits où vous avez beaucoup
de bleu des orangers là où il ya une
salle où il ya beaucoup de portraits
dans des mauvais depuis sept ans les
peintres se retrouvent assidûment tous
les mercredis soir à la villa simone
signoret à guyancourt autour d'une
professeur ils affinent leurs techniques
à l'atelier ou chez eux ils travaillent
avec la même minutie sur leur tableau au
début on commence par des choses un
petit peu classique sur un petit peu
peur de se lancer
et puis après
on cherche des choses un petit peu pas
plus particulière faye après feuilles
année après année ils ont appris à
maîtriser un art complexe
c'est une grande aventure avec l'eau
l'aquarelle c'est à dire que c'est
et on travaillait beaucoup beaucoup dans
l'eau qu'on ne maîtrise pas toujours
et parfois on a l'idée de faire quelque
chose
oui ça ne devient pas forcément ce qu'on
a décidé il faut improviser avec ce qui
se passe au niveau d'une feuille
l'exposition est à découvrir à la maison
félix à montigny le bretonneux jusqu'au
dimanche 1er février avec une nocturne
jusqu'à 21h ce vendredi c'est la fin de
ce journal dans un instant sur notre
antenne filets qu avec florame parfait
je vous retrouve demain vendredi 18
heures pour l'essentiel de l'actualité
de la semaine notamment très bonne
soirée